cette station spatiale va bientôt se
crasher dans ton jardin l'ISS et
au-dessus de nos têtes depuis 1998 mais
en 2031 c'est la fin trop vieille pour
être utile trop dangereuse pour rester
là mais comment la détruire on va la
faire descendre doucement jusqu'en
orbite basse à 400 km avec l'Afrique de
l'air elle va se casser en plusieurs
morceaux pour s'écraser au fond de
l'océan mais pas n'importe où au point
Némo des abysses océaniques au milieu du
Pacifique l'endroit le plus éloigné de
toute terre personne n'y passe voilà
pourquoi on y fait cracher tout ce qui
vient de l'espace un cimetière pour
satellite ça reste une grosse pression
un imprévu un mauvais calcul et les 420
tonnes de l'ISF pourraient tomber dans
ton jardin figurez-vous qu'on saura
peut-être obligé d'accélérer sa
destruction car avec la guerre en
Ukraine la Russie s'est retirée du
projet c'est le chaos à la NASA comment
faire marcher l'ISS jusqu'en 2030 si on
trouve rien alors